[Music]
neuro diversity is a pretty new term and
I'm very grateful for it it it gets to
something that is absolutely real and
has been harder to discuss before it
existed that said I'm not sure I have a
perfect definition it recognizes the
fact that we are not singular that we
are not all identical
that we have a variation of a brains of
connectivity of aptitudes of weaknesses
of blind spots and of sensitivities and
of capabilities people on the autism
spectrum who are who are very functional
in my experience tend to have
extraordinary analytical skills and also
often actually insight into social
interactions so long as they are not the
ones participating and so you have an
I've had a number of autistic students
actually point out to me dynamics that
were emerging in classrooms that I
hadn't yet seen and that once they were
pointed out I could see and these are
the same students who have a very hard
time recognizing when it is or is not
time to speak or get up or walk through
the middle of a classroom and such there
are a number of ways to be neuro-diverse
we have names for some conditions that
actually represent ends of continuum
dyslexia is is a big one these are going
to sound like they're coming out of left
field but colorblindness left handedness
in each of those cases being what in
evolutionary biology we call the
non-dominant phenotype so I am I'm a I'm
a lefty that's that's the one of those
that I belong to as a group and about
10% of people across all cultures that
have been studied are left-handed it's a
persistent stable rare phenotype which
suggests that it's adaptive that its
persistent its complex and it is it
provides the different wiring of the
brain associated with being a
left-hander
provides benefit in the social group in
which left-handers show up we can put
together analyses for why being a
left-hander might allow you to approach
a physical problem differently that a
right-hander would have a harder time
solving but the different wiring of the
brain allows for different approaches as
well similar with colorblindness that it
might be really easy to say well okay
that just is going to give you some some
ability to see past color and to see
patterns that aren't color based perhaps
but I I suspect that there's wiring in
the brain that is associated with
colorblindness that also allows for
enhanced abilities that are different
from those who are color sighted
dyslexia for sure right dyslexia is
obviously a very modern condition
because writing is a very modern
condition so as an evolutionary
biologist when I say modern I mean
thousands of years so dyslexia is modern
in terms of thousands of years and you
know language was always about sound and
never about writing until recently and
so the the lessened ability it's almost
never an inability but the lessened
ability to process written symbols into
meaning in your head looks to me like
it's an tradeoff relationship with the
ability to engage in real-time in speech
and that's not to say that all of us
can't learn through practice to be
better at any number of these skills but
that being born with what the world has
is calling a deficit is almost always
going to exist in trade off relationship
with some often hidden strength
[Music]